we are again hey Joe hello Jordan are
you doing man I'm doing great you have
the schedule that you have and the
amount of energy and enthusiasm you
maintain with the schedule is very
remarkable because you're not stopping
you're not slowing down I mean you've
had your foot on the gas for like two
solid years now make hay while the Sun
shines
I guess is that how you feel about it
well you know when you have an
opportunity that's completely
preposterous you're a fool to take it
for granted yes that's so and yeah so
Tammy and I have been to a hundred
cities since January so everywhere you
know and part of what keeps us going
well first of all I have a really good
crew you know like the CAA guys they're
really good Live Nation's been really
good they make sure the theaters are
smooth and and we've had no problems at
all
and then I have lots people who are
helping me with my scheduling and Tammy
travels with me and then the the
lectures themselves well I really like
doing them partly because I do a
different lecture every night and so
that keeps me sharp and it makes sure
that I'm thinking about new things all
the time and trying to formulate my
thoughts more precisely and they're all
so unbelievably positive so that's also
that that's also something that makes it
a lot easier to do because you know I go
to a city and there's 1,500 to 2,000
people waiting for me there which is
like a staggering in and of itself
wherever I go and they're all there
listening intently and and it's it's a
sophisticated discussion or at least as
sophisticated as I can make it I'm
communicating directly with the audience
and all the people are there to try to
get their lives together and so the the
feeling in the in the hall is really
really positive and then I usually talk
to about a hundred and fifty people
afterwards and you know they're they all
of them all of them while many of them
you know they just say hi and they're
polite and we have a photograph and all
that but lots of them have stories about
how they've been putting their lives
together and they're thrilled to death
about it you know that they're out of
the hole they were in or they've started
a new business or they've sold a new
business or they just decided to get
married or they're going to have some
kids or they've fixed up the
relationship with their parents or they
quit drinking or and they're they're not
addicted I talked to one guy in Europe
he'd stopped he was he was addicted I
don't remember what to but it wasn't was
something that wasn't good he'd stopped
for nine months got nine of his friends
to quit - so he comes up he's just like
bouncing you know he's so damn happy
that his life is better and not only
that that he had this additional
positive effect on other people so and
it's so fun because I have these
conversations with people they're brief
but they're very personal and they're
very intense you know because they they
you think people have to trust you to
tell you that their lives weren't going
so well and then they have to trust you
even more to tell you that they're going
better now because of course what you
want when you tell someone that things
are going better is you want real
encouragement and real sense from the
person you're talking to that they're
happy for you and I'm absolutely
thrilled to hear these things like I was
in Whole Foods this morning I went down
near where I'm standing and two of the
guys that worked behind the meat counter
came out to talk to me and independently
and they both been reading my books and
watching my lectures and one of them
said he had a seven-year-old son he
really wanted to do right by him he was
looking for ethical and moral guidance
and you know he found the books really
helpful and then it was helping him put
his life together and and so car guy at
the car rental place last night told me
the same thing and so it's so exciting
it's so ridiculously exciting to go
everywhere around the world and to go
into airports or to walk down the street
and have people come up and say I've
been watching you on YouTube they often
mention you I've been listening to what
you say I've been developing the vision
for my life it's really helped me a lot
thanks a lot and Jesus like to be able
to have that happen you know time after
time day after day all over the place
that's just absolutely it makes go into
a hundred cities like continually
energizing because it's so positive and
so and then there's all this weird crap
in the press you know about my dangerous
followers and all this all right
nonsense and it's so ridiculous you know
I've talked to 250,000 people in in in
seven months we haven't had one
incident that was negative in that
entire time not one nothing
no misbehavior on anyone's part we had
one heckler who was obviously not a fan
of mine given that he was a heckler that
was it
other than that the audience's behave
perfectly they all dress up they come in
suits which is really cool a lot of
young guys they dress up so they have a
little suit competition with me which is
quite fun so that's an additional bonus
and yeah it's it's pretty damn good Jill
I think it's really fantastic and I
think what's going on is it makes me
very optimistic because I think that one
of the things that new media has
provided as these new avenues for
information to get out there and these
new things like these lecture circuits
when was the last time you saw public
lecture circuits that were popular to
the tune of thousands and thousands of
people i saw the ones that you and sam
harris did on youtube and you know Sam's
doing them with a lot of other people as
well you're doing them with a bottle
with dave rubin as well yeah these are I
mean this is a very unique thing that's
for sure and also this desire to
understand new paths of behavior and
patterns of thinking and that these are
corrective paths and patterns that can
lead you to a more fulfilled and happier
life yeah and and recognize the pitfalls
of certain types of behavior that people
just fall into yep and I think
oftentimes the difference between
someone who lives a fulfilled life and
someone who lives a life filled with
disaster is following in correct
patterns and not knowing what the
correct ones are so there's a lot of
good people out there that live shitty
life and they don't do it because
they're they're just dumb or because
they're bad they do it because they've
been influenced by certain patterns
they've fallen into patterns whether
it's because of the people that they
surround themselves with or the the
neighborhood they grew up the the people
that around them have this way of being
and they kind of fall into that or it's
drugs or it's alcohol or whatever it is
but then they find a new one
you know and then they can slide right
into that new one and all sudden they
feel energized and they wake up in the
morning instead of hungover they're
getting exercise in they're eating
healthy they're starting to think about
things correctly and do good things and
the momentum of them doing those good
thing
leads them to feel good about themselves
and energized and they say these are all
things that you promote and I think are
genuinely really significant you know
really important